ancient human civilization is far older
and was far more advanced than we were
ever taught in school and the evidence
is overwhelmingly conclusive that
civilization was essentially reset
following a massive global Cataclysm
likely a comet or an asteroid impact to
the North American ice shelf nearly
13,000 years ago
not only does evidence conclude this
which I'll include later in this
presentation
but recent analysis taken at gobekli
tepe in turkey shows that they carved in
stone depictions of a comet impact to
Planet Earth that essentially was a
reset for human civilization which
validates the works from people such as
Graham Hancock Randall Carlson and
others now if you're not familiar with
gobekli tepe it's located in Turkey and
it is the world's oldest and largest
megalithic structure in fact it's more
than six thousand years older than
Stonehenge and more than 50 times bigger
as verified by ground-penetrating radar
it has more than 220 250 ton pillars
that have a cosmic orientation and in
fact it is the world's first perfectly
aligned north-south facing structure but
what makes it even more incredible is
that it's facing perfectly north himself
even taking into consideration magnetic
declination which it makes it more
accurate than a compass this site has
been dated to be eleven thousand six
hundred years old so the question
becomes how on earth were humans based
on what we were taught in the textbooks
able to have this type of astronomical
knowledge now besides the fact that
somehow unexplainably ancient humans
were able to cut and carve these stone
pillars list them as well as carve out
three-dimensional animals with
incredible precision and keep in mind
this site had been buried up until the
mid 90s when it was discovered it had
been buried for more than eleven
thousand six hundred years but it was
just recently announced by researchers
from the University of Edinburgh that
these depictions these animals located
throughout these stone pillars have a
cosmic and constellation orientation and
symbolism to them and when they've
combined computer software that takes
into account where the star
constellations were twelve thousand nine
hundred years ago which is the same
period of time where evidence shows that
there was
massive changes or a cataclysm here on
earth which I'll get you in just one
more second they were trying to depict a
comment or fragments of a comment impact
here on earth
now I've discussed the topic of the
global Cataclysm in other videos such as
the network of 200 underground cities
also located in Turkey
some of which are 11 stories deep more
than 200 feet underground had advanced
air shafts as well as a network of
tunnels some of which were three stories
underground and spanned five miles
through volcanic rock two other nearby
underground cities and these cities were
capable of holding tens of thousands of
people and livestock individually these
underground cities are absolutely
massive and they're a total mystery as
nobody knows who built them now keep
that in mind as I share with you
information from another video I made
that discuss in detail the overwhelming
evidence of a cosmic collision to the
North American Ice Shelf that happened
approximately twelve thousand nine
hundred years ago which would justify
the depictions taken at gobekli tepe
which essentially ancient humans were
trying to show and share a story or
perhaps to warn others of what had
happened before and as we know
everything in this universe appears to
be cyclic and if you take into the works
of Randall Carlson he outlines in detail
the overwhelming evidence that shows
that throughout time over the last 150
to 160 thousand years since modern
humans have the existed on planet Earth
there have been anywhere between nine
possibly a dozen global cataclysms that
would have completely decimated a human
civilization at that time which would
explain the fact on how modern humans
only date back roughly five thousand
years to ancient Sumerians in
Mesopotamia which would explain the
incredible gap between then and now and
how essentially there are cycles of
catastrophe here on earth so what's this
evidence of the cosmic collision well
there's a few things that happen all at
the same period of time twelve thousand
nine hundred years ago the rapid and
unexplainable end to the last ice age
that caused more than 400 foot rise in
global sea levels in a matter of years
and possibly as much as 30 feet
overnight and this has been confirmed
from recent core ice sample data taken
from Greenland and Antarctica there's
also a black matte layer called the
younger drier
boundary that covers more than 50
million square kilometers of the Earth's
surface at least three continents and
contains elements such as melt glass
nano diamonds iridium and
extraterrestrial helium all evidence of
a cosmic collision the same elements
found in the KT boundary which is agreed
upon in science to have been evidence of
the asteroid or comet impact that wiped
out the dinosaurs and there was also a
massive extinction level event of more
than 75% of all mammals in North America
including 120 species of mega fauna
mammals larger than a hundred pounds
which by the way is about approximately
as many mammals of that size that exists
throughout the entire planet earth today
and they all went extinct at the same
time and they're finding evidence such
as in Willi mammoths mass mortality
sites of more than a thousand Willy
mammoths many of them still have food in
their mouths and broken legs as if they
had been blasted over which completely
contradicts in debunks the mainstream
narrative of okay well hunters and
gatherers had made the woolly mammoths
go extinct now you might be wondering
why is this important keep in mind that
everything in the universe that we're
aware of happens in cycles so whatever
happened before will absolutely happen
again and there's a lot of evidence out
there that suggests that we're long
overdue for a magnetic pole shift for
maybe a rock from outer space hitting us
there could be all kinds of number of
different things that could happen here
on planet earth and it's important to
set humanity up for success so if there
is another Cataclysm we're not starting
back over from the Stone Age anyways
guys I'm going to leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe leave me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and I have
many other videos to come and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody